Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Avez-vous remarqué que certaines épreuves
de la vie vont déterminer vos choix
et vous faire progresser
sur votre propre chemin ?
Ma première épreuve à moi a eu lieu
la première fois, il y a douze ans.
C'était à Noël.
Nous étions très nombreux en famille.
J’ai souvenir que les parents riaient,
les enfants couraient un peu partout.
Et après avoir déballé
beaucoup de cadeaux,
mon fils de neuf ans, à l’époque,
arrive vers moi.
Il est triste et il me dit : « Maman, j’ai
eu moins de cadeaux que mon cousin. »
Je me dis : « Mais qu’ai-je
raté dans son éducation
pour qu’il puisse à son âge
comparer le nombre de ses cadeaux
comme d’autres pourraient
comparer la taille de leur télé ? »
Je me suis dit :
« Que puis-je faire
pour qu’il réalise à quel point
ils sont gâtés à notre époque ? »
Ah ! J’ai une idée.
Je suis allée voir ma grand-mère.
Ma grand-mère, elle s’appelait Mamie.
De Mamie,
je connaissais ses gelées de mûres,
elle les faisait divinement bien,
sans les petits grains.
Elle avait la peau douce,
j’appelais ça une peau de poulet.
Vous voyez, la peau des grands-mères ?
Elle sentait hyper bon.
Elle était très autoritaire,
extrêmement maniaque
et elle avait un petit Alzheimer
qui démarrait.
Donc je suis allée voir Mamie
et je lui ai dit :
« Qu’est-ce que tu avais, toi, à Noël,
quand tu avais neuf ans ? »
Après m’avoir raconté
qu’elle avait une poupée
qu’elle décortiquait toute l’année
pour voir ce qu’il y avait à l’intérieur,
elle m’a prise par la main
et elle m’a entraînée avec elle
dans les années 30, dans les années 40,
quand elle avait neuf ans.
Elle m’a parlé du pensionnat.
Elle m’a parlé de ses amis,
de ses punitions,
de son caractère très très effronté,
d’ailleurs, à l’époque.
Elle m’a aussi révélé qu’elle avait
un meilleur ami, qui s’appelait Théo,
que j’ai rencontré après.
Elle m’a aussi parlé
de choses très douloureuses
comme le froid, la guerre et la peur
qu’elle avait ressentie à cette époque.
Et là, en l’écoutant, j’ai réalisé à quel
point j’ignorais tout de ma grand-mère.
Parce que moi, ma grand-mère, quand
je la voyais, elle était née grand-mère.
Elle n’avait pas eu de vie,
elle était née en grand-mère.
Non ?
La deuxième épreuve qui détermine mes
choix aujourd'hui, ça remonte à cinq ans.
J'étais à l'enterrement
du papa d'une amie.
C'était au Père-Lachaise.
Nous étions une petite quarantaine
réunis autour du cercueil
et après des discours terriblement
émouvants de la famille, des amis,
qui disaient leur tristesse d’avoir
perdu un papa, un oncle, un ami,
je vis arriver deux hommes grisonnant,
une feuille de papier à la main.
Ils se sont approchés du cercueil.
Et ce qu’ils ont lu,
croyez-moi, c’était hyper-vivant.
C'était frais, c'était gai,
c'était dynamique.
Pourquoi ? Parce qu’en fait, ils
racontaient l’histoire du papa de mon amie
quand ils étaient jeunes avec lui.
Leur tour du monde, leurs folies,
leurs délires, leurs bêtises,
les filles, les sorties, les surfs.
On riait parce que c’était des existences
qui avaient eu lieu avant les nôtres.
Nous, on riait, mais mon amie
à côté de moi pleurait.
Elle pleurait beaucoup.
Alors je me suis retournée vers elle :
« Mais pourquoi tu pleures ? C’est... »
En fait, elle ne connaissait pas
ces deux hommes.
Elle ne connaissait pas ces histoires.
Et là, j’ai pris peur parce
que je me suis demandé
si vraiment il fallait attendre que
les gens meurent pour connaître leur vie.
Je pense que dans nos familles,
dans nos sociétés occidentales modernes,
on ne valorise pas assez nos aînés.
On oublie que leur regard, leur vécu,
leur expérience, sont précieux.
Et je vais vous dire, j’ai l’impression
que c’est pareil en entreprise.
On y va.
Imaginez, vous avez passé cinq ans,
dix ans, quinze ans,
vingt ans dans la même entreprise.
Vous la connaissez par cœur.
Vous l’avez vu grandir,
vous l’avez vu se développer,
s'ouvrir à de nouveaux marchés.
Vous avez participé
à des lancements de produits.
Vous connaissez ses clients.
Vous avez peut-être même
connu ses fondateurs.
Vous connaissez votre job.
Peut-être en avez-vous d’ailleurs eu
plusieurs dans la même société.
Vous avez du recul sur les choses.
Vous avez dû connaître
deux ou trois situations de crise.
Mais le jour où vous partez
ou le jour où vous prenez votre retraite,
il est possible que l’entreprise
vous laisse partir comme ça.
Il me semble que vous étiez
une personne précieuse pourtant,
et que vous auriez eu
pas mal de choses à transmettre,
à raconter, ne serait-ce que
pour faire gagner du temps
à ceux qui allaient prendre
le relais derrière vous.
Mais quand je regarde autour de moi,
il me semble que les entreprises -
certaines entreprises -
ne voient peut-être pas assez ça comme ça.
Il me semble qu’elles sous-estiment
le pouvoir de la transmission des valeurs,
de la culture et des mythes fondateurs
sur les nouvelles générations.
Par excès de jeunisme,
certaines vont même avoir tendance
à nettoyer leur stock de collaborateurs -
sortir les anciens.
Certains passeront d’ailleurs plus de
temps à négocier leurs accords de départ
qu’à transmettre leur savoir.
Mais bon, fermez la parenthèse.
Les licenciements de personnes
de plus de 45 ans,
ou les plans de départs à la retraite
à l’occasion de déménagements
ou de réorganisations
ont été de formidables aubaines
pour mettre fin, par anticipation,
à des contrats de personnes
qui avaient atteint leur DLC.
Ah oui, pardon,
ce n’est pas comme les œufs.
La DLC ici,
c’est la date limite de compétence.
Des pans entiers d’histoires, d’anecdotes,
d’expériences se sont envolés.
Pour moi, c’est un énorme gâchis collectif
et surtout - surtout -
une non-reconnaissance de la contribution
de chacun au projet commun.
Parce qu’en ne réussissant pas à capturer
le savoir-faire matériel et immatériel
de l’entreprise,
l’histoire, au lieu de se densifier,
va s’assécher,
va se simplifier.
Et je trouve ça hyper-dangereux.
Parce que les salariés toujours en poste
ou ceux qui arrivent aujourd’hui
se retrouvent dans une entreprise
un peu comme orphelins,
dans une entreprise sans cadre,
sans âme, sans histoire.
Un peu comme si on les avait coupés
de la cellule souche.
Or il me semble
qu’aujourd’hui on parle bien de ce sens
réclamé par les nouvelles générations.
À quoi sommes-nous reliés ?
Quel est notre socle commun ?
Pourquoi les entreprises ne réalisent pas
que ce savoir accumulé, ces expériences,
sont une valeur ajoutée ?
Sont une sorte de trésor vivant
qu'il faudrait protéger,
faire fructifier puis transmettre ?
Je vais vous donner une explication.
Quand vous avancez en âge,
quand vous vous approchez des 50 ans,
vous rentrez dans un monde
extraordinaire : celui des seniors.
Enfin, disons que l'entreprise
va vous y projeter.
Parce que plutôt que de regarder votre vie
comme une accumulation
d’expériences et de connaissances,
elle va avoir tendance à la regarder
comme un inventaire un peu poussiéreux,
inutilisable, un peu has been, quoi.
Ce n'est pas un paradoxe.
On vient de voter l'âge de départ
à la retraite à 64 ans.
Il y a un gap entre 50 et 64.
On va dire de vous que vous êtes
réfractaire au changement
et souvent dans la contradiction.
Et pour cause, vous avez un peu
d’expérience quand même,
vous pouvez défendre des projets.
Passé 55 ans, vous aurez beaucoup
moins de formations.
Définitivement, vous allez regarder
derrière vous et vous dire : « Hop hop,
la période des hauts potentiels
est définitivement derrière,
elle n’est plus devant. »
En fait, ces trois exemples, ça fait
partie de ce qu'on appelle l'âgisme.
C’est un mouvement qui est apparu, dit-on,
au moment de la révolution industrielle,
au moment où il y avait
trois mots-clés qui étaient érigés,
qui étaient ceux de la force,
de la mobilité et de la rapidité.
Alors forcément, si vous ne
correspondiez pas à ces critères,
vous étiez un peu mis à la marge.
Ah j’oubliais, si vous cherchez
un job après 55 ans, ça va être dur.
Parce qu’aujourd’hui, c’est le premier
facteur de discrimination à l’embauche.
Je vais le [dire] une deuxième fois.
Aujourd'hui, l'âge est le premier facteur
de discrimination à l'embauche.
En fait, certaines entreprises
nous font vieillir prématurément.
Je pense que
dans nos sociétés occidentales,
on a tendance à regarder nos aînés
avec les yeux du présent.
On les voit en décalage, on se demande
comment ils vivent les changements
alors qu’en réalité, on devrait
les regarder avec les yeux du passé.
Se demander ce qu'ils ont vécu,
ce qu'ils ont appris.
Parce qu’en réalité,
ils ne sont pas vieux,
ils sont en avance sur nous.
Vous serez d’accord,
on ne peut pas opposer
ce que nous avons été, ce que
nous sommes et ce que nous serons,
parce que nous nous améliorons sans cesse.
Vous êtes le même, monsieur,
je suis la même,
en différent à chaque nouvelle mue.
L'écrivaine Perla Servan-Schreiber
le dit un peu différemment.
Elle dit que dans la vie normale,
le mot « senior » n’existe pas.
Elle dit qu’on est jeune,
puis on est moins jeune, puis on vieillit,
puis on est vieux,
puis on est très vieux, c’est tout.
Et quand il y a de la vie,
la vieillesse n’existe pas,
puisqu’il ne reste que la vie en réalité.
Mais alors, pourquoi ?
Pourquoi hésitons-nous encore
à partager et échanger nos savoirs,
nos connaissances et nos expériences
entre générations ?
Nous partageons bien la même planète,
les mêmes ressources,
le même oxygène que nous respirons.
Je ne suis pas d’accord avec ce que
dit George Orwell quand il déclare
que chaque génération se croit
plus intelligente que la précédente
et plus sage que la suivante.
Oui, c’est vrai, c’est vrai,
on est différents,
mais ces différences doivent nous servir
et doivent profiter à tous.
Ne nous opposons pas parce que
ces différences, en réalité, se complètent
et s'enrichissent.
D'ailleurs, regardez autour de vous.
Dans ce monde en transformation permanente
où les questions même
d’existence des entreprises,
du sens du travail ou de l’impact de
l’intelligence artificielle sont en jeu,
comment peut-on encore
passer à côté du potentiel
que représente la présence de cinq
décennies dans une organisation ?
C’est Antonio Guterres lui-même, le
secrétaire général [de l’ONU], qui le dit.
Il déclare ceci :
« Il est de notre
responsabilité collective
de tout mettre en œuvre
pour assurer les transitions écologiques,
sociales et sociétales du monde à venir.
La coopération intergénérationnelle
est définitivement le meilleur
moyen pour affronter l’avenir. »
La bonne nouvelle, c’est qu’il y a
des entreprises qui ont déjà compris
que l'avenir sera intergénérationnel
ou ne sera pas.
C’est le résultat de l’étude
que j’ai confiée à la Junior HEC,
qui m’ont fait une étude internationale
des meilleures initiatives
intergénérationnelles dans le monde.
Et ce que j’ai découvert se passe en
Corée, au Japon, en France ou au Canada.
Écoutez.
Il y a par exemple un programme
qui réunit des salariés
juniors et seniors,
qui les met ensemble pour partager
sur des sujets d’actualité,
pour développer leur empathie.
Ou cet autre sujet
qui valorise la diversité des
âges dans l’entreprise
et qui s’assure que les salariés seniors
aient bien un accès
à toutes les opportunités d’emploi.
Ou cet autre programme
qui valorise les compétences
accumulées des plus âgés
et qui les fait évoluer
vers des métiers de mentors
vis-à-vis de la nouvelle génération.
Moi-même, dans mon activité
professionnelle, aujourd’hui,
j’ai créé des ateliers de
co-développement intergénérationnel.
Je vous explique.
Je réunis huit à dix personnes ensemble,
dans une pièce, dans une salle
d’âges différents.
L’objectif, c’est de résoudre ensemble,
grâce à ces expériences cumulées,
les problématiques des uns et des autres.
Que me disent les seniors ?
Ils me disent qu'ils ont rajeuni.
Ils ont rajeuni parce qu'en fait, les
jeunes leur ont apporté des solutions
qu’ils n’avaient même pas imaginées.
Et les juniors me disent :
« On vient de gagner 15 ans d’expérience
parce qu’on a eu sur nous
les regards et les conseils
de gens matures et plus expérimentés. »
C’est simple en fait,
c’est du gagnant-gagnant.
Non ?
À chaque fois que j’y pense, et
même en en reparlant là, je me dis que
c'est inouï le potentiel qu'il y a dans
vos entreprises, dans les entreprises.
J’aimerais conclure avec des conseils
que j’aimerais vous donner ce soir.
Ne regardez pas l'âge chronologique, mais
regardez l'âge à la lumière des capacités.
Soyez curieux.
Soyez à la fois transmetteur et récepteur.
Acceptez le fait que
vous ne savez pas tout.
Acceptez aussi le fait que ce
que vous voyez, la réalité,
n’est que votre réalité.
Et que fatalement, nous tous ici,
nous ne sommes que de passage.
J’aimerais que vous
me fassiez une promesse.
Dans les prochaines semaines,
je vous invite
à aller à la rencontre de la vie passée
d’une personne de votre entourage.
Questionnez-la sur sa vie,
sur ses conseils et sur ses rêves.
Et promettez-moi une dernière chose :
n’attendez pas Noël pour le faire.
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)